do you have concerns I mean obviously
you have concerns for your for your
children over this
yeah I mean the way I put it to the jury
when I was put on a stand was very
simple I said you know if my sons go
with me
they have a chance at a normal life
if they go with her they have no chance
at a normal life and a good chance of
living a life of despair
and that's the choice that's the
Hobson's choice that we're giving all of
these children right and they're they're
so obsessed with puberty blockers
because the cure for gender dysphoria is
called puberty puberty is the cure for
gender dysphoria puberty is the process
by which you come to identify with the
social psychological and physical
aspects of your sex
that's what puberty actually is and so
they desperately have to block puberty
to maintain the gender dysphoria